let me see your poker face let me see it
[Music]
very intense poker face well every sport
has its greats football is tom brady
hockey it's gretzky basketball has
jordan and for the world series of poker
it's stan cates the poker champion who
is joining us now it's good to see you
buddy well it's good to be on the show
and nice to meet you so can you say how
much money you've won playing poker
uh total well not all of it's mine but
somewhere in the tens of millions
oh
tens of millions of dollars so what is
the world series of poker for someone
that's not familiar with what is the
world series of poker okay so the world
series of poker is one of the biggest
collection of tournaments and the
biggest collection of players that comes
right to right here in las vegas and
they play for enormous amounts of money
um
and there's also kinds of events and
it's possible to win millions of dollars
if you get lucky or if you have the
skills mix of the above and uh that's
pretty much what it is what it is and
some of the best players in the world
come here and you can meet them and play
with them on the table in a tournament
or cash game or whatever yeah it's
basically a big opportunity to win a lot
of money and
let your skills shine when did you know
you had a talent when did you know
you're good at poker and you start
winning millions and millions of dollars
playing poker uh you know what that's
the funny thing is that when i started
off playing poker i was actually very
bad
i got a chance yeah yeah well i would i
could beat my friends but then when i
played in a little bit tougher game
against more experienced players i got
destroyed for a few months and i
actually went down the smallest stakes
and i had to work at mcdonald's to even
get some money because i had spent a lot
of my parents money
no not their parents my parents money
but the money that they gave me uh that
it was in savings and all that how uh
how do you work on your poker face
but it's five cards right three four is
that poker's five cards sort of it's
it's two each
five cards two cards i'm already ruining
my game of poker so the poker face the
classic poker face is just not smiling
before when you were doing it i was a
little scared myself
uh but yeah just not smiling and looking
very serious and intimidating but
hypothetically you could uh
have a poker face of just being happy
all the time it's just not letting your
emotions
not laying what actually happens
externally affect what what your face
looks like on the outside it's it's more
about um same same person win or lose
ideally so you go into a game and i'm a
happy person i got to keep that happy
face the entire time even if i have a
bad hand in front of me kind of yeah but
at least when at least when you're
actually in the pot with the players and
like is this your poker face i can't
tell you is this your the look you give
me right now for playing poker is this
your poker face kinda yeah yeah i'd
probably have something like this i
might it depends i might have they have
be giving some jokes or something like
that you dress up too i've heard that
you actually dress up at some when you
go play you dress up uh yeah i try to
keep things entertaining and
a lot of times in tournaments people are
very serious and i don't like that i
find it boring and i want to make things
more fun so i you know dress up as
characters and all that kind of thing
let's steal about a minute 30 deal a
hand here and then tell me what it
should be when it comes to playing poker
okay so the the basic
premise of poker is pretty simple it's
you just you want to basically you want
to get people to fold when they've got
nothing when you've got something you
want to get the most value
and when they've got something you want
to get out of there that's pretty much
what you want to do and it's like life
in many ways many people have
different kind of ways of dealing with
life like sometimes they they don't go
for it they don't have the courage or or
they back away but you want to do things
at the right time and the right kind of
hand you have so like with these threes
i would want to just like see a showdown
i don't want to get into too much
trouble with these threes now with your
hand it's kind of the same thing so we
would probably not do too much
with uh do i have a winning hand
yeah yeah you do and you've got a losing
hand well we both have a winning hand so
maybe this is actually game of poker who
would win right now uh i would win
but yeah if you had like a ace queen
or something in this case yeah there
goes the queen where can we watch the
world series of poker where can we watch
you work your magic uh
on um poker go okay and this is
something that you won too just recently
what's this right here this this
beautiful bracelet you won this yeah
it's a bracelet that you get if you win
one of these tournaments and i'm going
to be battling the challengers who are
going to try to take this from me well
no no no i can take it but they're going
to try to take the championship on the
26th and uh i'll be defending my title i
got a feeling you're going to win yeah
well thank you yeah good thank you so
much dan i really appreciate it this is
uh this is this is a pleasure good luck
you don't need it thank you but good
luck for me too the world series of
poker check out dan doing his thing it's
it's happening here in las vegas rocky
i'm going to send it over